معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد ما الذي حدده رد نتنياهو
بخصوص التعامل مع ما صدر في قرار محكمه
لاهاي ما يقلق اسرائيل من هذا القرار هي
ان الاوامر القضائيه التسعه او الاحكام
المؤقته التي اصدرتها محكمه لاهاي ابقت
اسرائيل متهمه داخل قفص الاتهام بما يتعلق
والدعوه التي قدمتها دوله جنوب افريقيا
بانها تمارس حرب او جريمه اباده جماعيه
بحق الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه هذا الامر
على الرغم من ان اسرائيل ذهبت الى الترويج
لما لم ياتي على ذكره القرار مباشره وهو
وقف تام لاطلاق النار والسماح بعوده
النازحين الى شمالي قطاع غزه الا ان هذه
الاحكام والاوامر ترى اسرائيل بانها
بمثابه اتهام لها عليها ان تثبت عكسه على
مدار شهر مقبل من خلال الردود التي ستبعث
الى المحكمه في على الاحكام او الاوامر
القضائيه الصادره هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى ما يقلق اسرائيل فعلا بان من اجل
تنفيذ هذه الاوامر والاحكام يتطلب ذلك
وقفا لاطلاق النار والسماح للمواطنين
بالعوده والاهم وهو ربما يقلق نتنياهو
اكثر من غيره بانه بما ان اسرائيل لم تحدد
حتى الان رؤيه او اليه لاداره قطاع غزه
بعد بعد انتهاء الحرب او في اليوم التالي
للحرب فان هذا الوضع قد ي يضع اسرائيل في
موقف حرج اما ان تتخذ قرارا بهذا الخصوص
او ان ما يحذر منه الجيش صباح هذا اليوم
ومساء اليوم يحذر القياده السياسيه قد بدا
بالفعل وهو ان
موظفين مدنيين من حركه حماس بداوا بالعوده
الى منطقه شمال قطاع غزه وتنظيم واداره
الامور هناك وهو ما يشكل ضغطا على نتنياهو
الذي يماطل ويحاول التهرب من قضيه الرؤيه
الاسرائيليه لليوم التالي للحرب والتي
تطالب بها الولايات المتحده والقيادات
الامنيه والعسكريه هذا القرار من جانب
المحكمه العليا عدل العليا الدوليه في
لاهاي اثبت لاسرائيل مجددا او وضعها على
مفترق طرق بان افلاتها من العقاب قد يكون
قد وصل نهايته وانها من اليوم ايضا تخضع
للقانون الد
وليست فوق هذا القانون او كما قال بعض من
علقوا بانها كانت تتصرف منذ بدايه انشائها
75 عاما وكان هناك قانون دولي خاص بها
وقانون دولي خاص بباقي العالم لذلك هي
تنظر الى القرار على انه بمثابه بطاقه
صفراء رفعتها المحكمه امام اسرائيل وايضا
من يساندها لان القرار سيتم نقله وبدايه
البحث في اليه تنفيذه في مجلس الامن
الدولي وهذا اصبح غايه في الاحراج بالنسبه
لها في هذه الحرب وامامها الان شهر للرد
عليه لذلك سارعت بدايه الى الترويج بان
القرار لا يدعوها مباشره او لم ياتي على
ذكر وقف اطلاق النار او عوده النازحين الى
شمالي القطاع ولكنه مثلما وصفه نتنياهو
امر مشين وايضا وصمه عار ان تبحث المحكمه
تهمه ان اسرائيل
تقترف جريمه اباده جماعيه لانها كانت
دائما تتصرف وكانها فوق القانون الامر
الثاني الذي جاءت عليه الاوامر القضائيه
ويقلق اسرائيل وهو ان مساله حقها في
الدفاع عن نفسها لا تعني باي حال من
الاحوال حرمان الفلسطينيين من الحق في
الحياه وعليها ان تتصرف وفق القانون وان
تقدم الادله على انها لا تمارس عمليه
اباده للفلسطينيين او حرمانهم من حقهم في
الحياه والعيش الكريم بكل ما يجري في قطاع
غزه وهذه في مجملها تخشى اسرائيل ان تقود
بالفعل الى ان يصدر قرارا من مجلس الامن
بوقف بوقف القتال او وقف الحرب في قطاع
غزه هي تحاول ان تستند ايضا الى ان القرار
جاء في اوامره يطالب بالافراج الفوري عن
كافه الرهائن الاسرائيليه في قطاع غزه لكن
هي تدرك جيدا بان المحكمه نقطه تحول ايضا
بالنسبه للراي العام العالمي وليس فقط على
الصعيد القضائي وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره في رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك